Batman had had a long legacy on both the
big and small screens with everyone from
Clooney to a flick taking a turn under
the cow I've seen you go through similar
phases in 2016 in 2012 and 2008 and 2005
in 1997 in 1995 and 1992 with 1989 and
that weird one in 1966 I have aged
phenomenally with will arnett being the
most recent actor to be welcomed into
the bat club we thought it would be fun
to test his knowledge of that chin I
guess we're get away collect it that is
um George Clooney no no no no no no no
no no no no no gosh I hope we were
recording that personally Ben Affleck
that's George wait that's uh Michael
gene I've know those lift anywhere
that's that Christian Bale ok Christian
Bale yeah few more to go that is a
danger detention no that's me someone
who's crazy wealthy stupid good-looking
but it's also just a down-to-earth rad
dude am i right and as well oh my god
those were vowels James Adam West you
know which money is a lot more noise
sticking out on the Adam West version
you sought yourself not great for
disguise yeah they should accomplish
that was fun brought to you by the lego
batman movie I love it I got an idea rip
better I can only look you in the eyes
right now see it in theaters februari 10